now we take you to the national press
club in washington DC for Pulitzer
prize-winning author Edward Wilson his
new book the future of life explores the
impact of humanity on the course of the
natural world during this hour and ten
minute discussion mr. Wilson maps out a
plan of action to prevent further
habitats and species loss across the
globe not only is our guest a scientist
with a worldwide reputation for his work
studying the very small and complex
world of ants but he has been in the
forefront of the formation of the macro
concept of the interconnectedness of all
life his new book continues his mission
to educate us about the destructive role
that we humans play in the biosphere and
what we have to lose if we continue to
pursue our current course of limitless
growth with his skill as a writer he
makes us care for the ecosystem of a dry
antarctic valley populated by
unpronounceable bacteria almost as much
as we care for the lonely endangered
sumatran right now keystrokes at the zoo
we are indeed fortunate to have him here
tonight to share his wonder at the
marvelous creatures large and small that
inhabit the earth and he will outline
his ideas for their preservation that
are in this new book the future of life
please join me in welcoming mr. Edward
Wilson
Thank You Virginia and thank you all for
coming tonight I'm very grateful for
this opportunity in this very special
setting to speak to the issue closest to
my heart the reconciliation of humanity
in nature have you ever wondered how we
will be remembered a thousand years and
now when we are as remote as Charlemagne
most I believe would choose something
like the following techno scientific
revolution ongoing accelerating
globalized unstoppable computer capacity
approaching that of the human brain semi
autonomous robots at work genetic
engineering perfected space colonized
overpopulation abating government's
turning the democracy trade globalized
and people better fed and healthier but
in this bouillon view shared by so many
of the ultimate outcome of the 21st
century what might have we overlooked
about our place in history what are we
neglecting at the price of losing and
the price of losing something precious
forever the answer most likely in the
year 3000 is the following much of the
rest of life or if you would prefer of
the creation a lot of our environmental
security and just as important part of
what it means to be human our relation
to the rest of life can be put in a
nutshell as follows first in the last
several decades scientists have found
the biosphere to be far richer and
diversity than imagined previously then
second that biodiversity which took over
three billion years to evolve is being
eroded at an accelerating rate by human
activity and third that loss was going
to inflict a heavy price in wealth and
security and spirit an overall and brief
summary it is time to think about the
human condition and more vile
logical terms all together the 21st
century is destined in my opinion to be
the century of the environment with
strong biological twist the immediate
future is usefully conceived of as a
bottleneck of overpopulation and rising
per capita consumption science and
technology combined with a lack of self
understanding and a Paleolithic
obstinacy that led to our ruinous
environmental practices have brought us
to where we are today and so science and
technology combined with foresight and
moral courage both guided by a more
enlightened ethic macias through the
bottleneck of overpopulation and well
and wasteful consumption and out one
hopes by the end of the century and
carrying with us as much of the
diversity of life as we can manage to
collateral effects of the bottleneck
phenomenon or especially worrisome the
first is that the rich go richer the
poor go pour the uncommon difference
between the fifth of the world's
population in the wealthiest countries
and the fifth in the poorest countries
was thirty to one in nineteen sixty
sixty to one in 1990 and now it's 74 to
1 800 million people deny it as we might
like to remain in what the United
Nations classifies as absolute poverty
no sanitation no clean water rampant
disease and periodic starvation even if
the income differential is dismissed as
a humanitarian their issue I think all
will agree that it has become a security
issue it's the dangerous setting for
resentment and fanaticism and the
arrival of heaven built suicide bombers
from who knows how many small developing
and desperate countries the second
collateral effect and the one to which
I'd like to devote my time this evening
is the accelerating destruction of the
natural environment
leading to mass extinction of I
ecosystems and species the damage
already done can't be repaired in any
period of time that has meaning for the
human mind the more it's allowed to grow
because it involves millions of years in
the making the biodiversity that is
affected the more future generations
will suffer from this loss in ways that
we understand now and have yet to
imagine why future generations will ask
by needlessly extinguishing the lives of
others of other species you diminished
our own the radical reduction of the
world's biodiversity is the folly arms
descendants are least likely to forgive
us so let me now before I move on and
proof you that I'm not your standard
liberal Harvard professor with a
suggestion for solutions that I hope
will be regarded as ideology free and
argue there by for a nonpartisan view of
the solution to this key part of the
environment oven of our environments
problems let me begin then by reviewing
a few basic facts about biodiversity
first what is it well biologist would
say if they had to define it in one
phrase it's all of the hereditary
variability of life on earth well in
order to prevent that from being fatal
they slice it horizontally into three
levels of biological organization at the
top are the ecosystems like mangrove
swamps the shallow marine estuaries
forest lakes savannas and so on the next
level down are the species that composed
the ecosystems
and we tend to use species when we do
quantitative studies with biodiversity
because they are relatively discrete and
easily recognized and they can be
counted and they can be followed through
geological history in many cases to
determine their origin and they're
likely fate and then finally are the
genes the variation in the genes that
make up each species in turn how many
species are there are scientists have
thought up during the past 250 years
I've been working on the the exploration
and classification of life on Earth have
come up with diagnosis and names based
on museum specimens of somewhere between
1.5 and 1.8 million species of these by
far the most abundant are the insects
750,000 known species that's a
phenomenon largely unsolved in
evolutionary theory as to why there are
so many insect species but as I'll
mention in just a moment it may turn out
that they will prove to be dwarfed by
the prokaryotes that is the bacteria and
the superficially similar are kian's and
among the photosynthetic organisms the
most diverse are the flowering plants
with some 300,000 species and the coal
regnum of of insects and and flowering
plants it's not a coincidence it's due
to coevolution between these two major
groups it began with the rise of the
flowering plants and the late mesozoic
so we are in the age of insects and
angiosperms that's really what it comes
down to biologically
as I mentioned briefly just now this
picture may radically change with the
particularly as we get down to the level
of bacteria and other microorganisms and
begin a full exploration and this will
be a necessary next step in the near
future and also something that can be
success in the next generation and it
will then lead us to make some kind of
allow us to make some kind of an
estimate of just how much biodiversity
is there is on this earth because while
1.5 to 1.8 million species are now known
scientific names the estimates of the
actual number of species ranges from
what I think is a much too conservative
3 million all the way up to over a
hundred million in short biologists
using different methods focusing on
their expectations from different little
explored groups come up this wide range
of possible estimation we do not know
how much species diversity there is on
planet Earth to the nearest order of
magnitude earth is a little-known little
explored planet waiting the next
generation of biologists and in this
century of the full accounting of how
much of the quality of life and quantity
of life there is surrounding us at the
present time there is a move afoot as a
matter of fact to complete such a survey
to speed it up many many times using the
most advanced methods and rapidly
evolving exponentiating methods of of
bioinformatics of genomic studies of of
internet publication that I believe can
accelerate our our studies of the
diversity of life at the species level
up to two orders of magnitude as much as
the hundred times
and so in October at Harvard we had a
summit meeting of all the various
initiatives around the world about a
half dozen major ones included the heads
of them to start settling upon a master
plan to accomplish this and agreed that
we thought that we think it can be
accomplished in 25 years how much would
it cost several billion dollars the
price per species will drop radically
and as the species their discoveries and
and and and and diagnoses increase and
in fact we would expect that to parallel
in its history and the way the the time
that expenses dropped and per species
dropped and as it would be paralleled it
will parallel the Human Genome Project
which seemed impossible at the beginning
like a moon a moon shot of science but
as the team's of molecular geneticists
preceded the cost per base pair dropped
and dropped and dropped and the troll
process of the mapping speeded up and up
and up and they came in three years
ahead of schedule and I think that the
attenti chol process can be done in the
exploration of planet Earth biodiversity
bacteria as I met as i mentioned would
are a great barrier at the present time
we only know about 5,000 species because
we had to use old-fashioned biochemical
and culturing methods to do it but now
there are methods a shotgunning method
of genomic identification of doing that
identifying the genetic code enough of
it to identify species which allows us
to identify species of bacteria and as
quickly as a few days I mean that's
that's right on the immediate horizon
but there are other methods including
ones now ongoing being tried out at
Harvard and elsewhere i'm sure it splits
the DNA molecule and runs them through
what are called nanopores i want to get
too technical but these are tiny tiny
narrow pores about a nanometer a
billionth of a meter across
and and pushes them through and as they
come through read the base pairs by
differences in conductance in the
various and the four nucleotides we can
read the code super fast it's estimated
that if this method can be perfected we
would be able to read the human genome
it would take years it would it would
take a matter of days or possibly even
hours and your degree the virus in
seconds and identified so if we can get
to this point then and this seems to be
something like this seems possible so
that we can go searching for bacterial
faunas with microscopes and this
equipment the way you go into a forest
searching for birds and identifying them
and then we're really moving in the
world biodiversity map in terms of genes
it's worth noting the enormous diversity
that exists there if you take for
example the for DNA molecule from a
typical human cell and humans in turn
our typical eukaryotic advanced
organisms in this respect and you put
them in the end you have in real space a
molecule real molecule about a metre
long but it's only two nanometers across
two billion so meet across we couldn't
see that molecule affion as you uncoil
it you wouldn't you wouldn't get the
spiral of the helix out should get the
all these doublings up in coiling I'll
that that allow this the DNA to be
packed into this tiny tiny nucleus frame
out two meters and now she could
magically increase the width of the DNA
molecule that you have there to the
width of a wrapping string now you can
see it clearly in and you lay it out it
would now cover now that's visible to
you 1820 miles well you would walk along
that string if you dared if you chose to
which would reach from New York to
Dallas one cell
and you would read off base pairs at the
rate of about a hundred per inch that's
how much genetic information or a large
part of it is in a typical organism and
it gives some indication of what we lose
when we allow a species to go extinct
where is biodiversity found everywhere
there is liquid water of the potential
of liquid water pole to pole from the
summit of Everest to the Challenger Deep
36,000 feet below the ocean surface at
the very least there are bacteria and
other microorganisms particularly
microscopic fungi some of which thrive
in water above the boiling point and
thermal vents on the sea floor there's
there is one pyro lobis which can only
breathe successfully above the boiling
point of water and you cool it down to
the boiling point of water it begins to
get sick it can't do very well there are
organisms recently discovered 252 miles
or more down below the earth's surface
all new forms of bacteria and fungi that
draw the energy from the metabolism in
or inorganic molecules there they don't
need us they don't need energy and
materials filtering down they are
self-sustaining so if we burned the
surface to a crisp they would go on
living down there that's what's this
discovery is what is given exobiologist
hope that we will find life on Mars and
who knows perhaps and below the ice caps
of Europa and Callisto when we first
start looking these are called the
slimes these newly discovered organism
that stands for subterranean little
autotrophic microbial ecosystems and yes
that will be on the exam
most of the species of known organisms
occur in the tropical rainforest and
that cover these forests cover only
about six percent of the earth's land
surface that they are down about
one-half or a little more from their
original cover before humanity came
along the rainforests are in an early
stage particular of exploration in part
because so much of the diversity of life
itself is found in the canopy very
difficult to get to as I know myself
having tried it it's the trees come
typically straight up with the trunks
either smooth really hard to get a grip
on or with spines and the branches often
don't come until near the count of
yourself way up and they go out almost
horizontally in many cases and they are
covered in masses of orchids or gays
neri ads or tactile fights that grow up
their whole gardens that are found only
up there and they team with colonies of
ants and stinging wasp and it's obvious
that Tarzan would not have survived 15
minutes
young athletic scientists especially
biologists of both sexes sexes are
learning are getting up there now
they're doing it by rope climbing
technique they the French have innovated
the method of bringing an airship over
the canopy and lowering a cargo net down
on the canopy which can support a cargo
net and then the size of rappel down you
know like a SWAT team on it and spread
out and study the top of it right there
and then they go back up one of my one
of my former students mark Moffat was a
National Geographic photographer and
writer now went on one of their
expeditions and he said very risky but
the food was terrific another method is
to is to be being used by the
Smithsonian Tropical Research Institute
to refer to another washington-based
organization is to trundle a building
crane out to the edge of the forest and
then you swing the arm out over the
trees and an investigator or a group of
investigators in a gondola can go out be
then pulled out to the end or sent out
to the end of the crane crane can be
swung around and they can go up and down
and that's allowed very efficient
studies where no one has ever gone
before a right at the tips of the trees
where the photosynthesis is taking place
I would emphasize that one does not have
to go to temperate forests however to
engage in the raw exploration of I mean
of tropical fart to engage in the raw
expiration of new species and every
biologist who works on biodiversity of
the systematics is swamped with new
species I've just finished describing
335 in one genus from the new world
that's ten percent of all the ants known
from the new world you can explore
particularly in small organisms and I
like to address this to students and
young people planning on careers
thinking about what can they can do
that's very effective and teachers who
want to introduce students to science
through field studies and real original
research you can do this anywhere you
can do it in the in the woodlands and
rock creek park i can assure you there
are new species right there of nematode
worms of little mite spider like
creatures and these are not trivial
these are not marginal organisms they
are these form part of the base of the
ecosystem they are more abundant than
almost anywhere else any other organisms
and and they are the main engineers of
the of the turning of the of materials
and energy in in the litter other areas
that are yield a surprising discovery
that's for example the the the most
abundant photosynthetic organism in the
world was just discovered about 20 years
ago prochlorococcus which is a ultra
microscopic bacterium that lives in the
open ocean and maybe it was almost
extremely difficult to find because you
can't see it with optical microscopy you
have to get it with electron microscopy
and this is an organism which is thought
to produce a very large amount of the of
the organic matter of the of the ocean
and so on you could spend a lifetime of
exploration if you went to the small
organisms discovering new species
working out new parts of the ecological
cycles discovering how a species
interact with 10 you can spend a
lifetime in a Magellanic voyage around
the single tree trunk that's the point I
want to make right outside it is a
destruction of habitats that is causing
the greatest damage just to give you an
acronym to help memory on what are the
factors causing extinction of species
worldwide habitat destruction invasive
species pollution population
overpopulation and overharvesting in
that order with population increase
their sort of thrown in because we have
to put it in somewhere and that's of
course at the root of so much of the
others hip hold the acronym is have a
habitat destruction invasive species
pollution population over harvesting
over you know over utilizing these
resources and driving species into
extinction the NASA has determined in
terms of habitat destruction for example
that we burn about 5% of the land
surface every year the loss of forest
worldwide is about one of tropical
forests particularly one percent per
year florist the tropical forest with
some of the richest most magnificent
Flores and faunas of the world have been
driven to below ten percent in some of
the most damaged parts of the
environment the state of são Paulo with
the Atlantic its unique Atlantic forest
to ten percent of cod regional cover the
Philippine Islands cut within the last
century to ten percent of its original
cover madagascar about the same and we
know pretty precisely the relation
between the area
an island or part of a continent and the
number of species that can live there
sustainably when you reduce the area of
a habitat whether it is the area of an
island out in the ocean whether it is a
habitat island as we call them like a
patch of forest you are you reduced the
number of species that can go on living
there by between approximately between
the third and the sixth root of the area
the most common value is the fourth root
it's a very common value and I'll
translate that into a rule of thumb
which is reduce the area to ninety
percent as in the Philippines parts of
Brazil and Madagascar and many other
parts of the word reduce it by ninety
percent to ten percent you reduce the
number of species that can live there to
one half and that happened for example
in the in Puerto Rico which went to ten
percent and this 20 / 20 or so original
bird species went to 22 about 12 and it
would been less than that if we hadn't
had heroic efforts to save the Puerto
Rican parrot and so on around the world
so you get a picture that a hat to
remove half the rainforest of the world
and a half of many or more of many of
the other habitats by habitat reduction
alone has got to be to have a massive
effect the remaining cover of the
tropical rainforest today is about equal
to the 40 in area to about the 48
coterminous United States it's being
reduced at a rate of about one half to
all of Florida that area every year this
translates to about in pure terms with
that fourth root relation to about a
quarter of one percent a quarter of the
one percent of all the species living in
the tropical rainforest being committed
either extinguished outright a committed
early extinction / here and then in
addition to
continue this this gloomy dispatched to
you from the conservation in front there
are the invasive species spread
intentionally or accidentally by people
at an accelerating rate around the world
like the friendly fire ant that came to
the south from from South America to the
zebra mussel which is pushing back the
mollusk fauna of the Midwest and has now
Puddle hopped all the way to New England
and then run down all the way to the
Gulf Coast there is the horrid brown
tree snake I find it difficult to say of
any species of organism that is hard but
I will say of this one introduced from
either the Solomon Islands or New Guinea
to Guam after the Second World War and
proceeded to wipe out the entire land
bird fauna including three species of
birds found nowhere else so they're
globally extinguished by this one snake
which grows to be about 10 feet long is
poisonous and when it ran out of native
birds to eat started invading chicken
coops then of course the chestnut blight
fungus with most of us have heard of
which essentially exterminated the the
American chestnut which once made up
twenty-five percent of America's eastern
forest trees the woolly adelgid a little
even like creature introduced into the
united states has eliminated about half
of the conifers of the appalachian these
invasive species now number thousands
and they're increasing with
international trade and they are washing
over the world and adding to the damage
of habitat destruction how fast our
species going extinct by three separate
measures and I'll mention this you know
too in case you've heard any any serious
doubts about this well this is what we
think it is by three separate measures
that relation between area and species
number that I just indicated by tracking
directly the change in the
of species as they move down the ratchet
of the Red Data whisper of the read data
list of endangered species that is they
species enter from reasonably safe to
vulnerable at a certain point as they
their ranges shrink and they get scarce
or and scarcely from vulnerable then
there are reclassified as they go on
down to endangered then to critically
endangered and finally when the evidence
is indisputable after a long time
searches for them fail to find anything
like the ivory-billed woodpecker they
are declared extinct so the velocity
with which species are moving down the
ratchet and the in the red data list
gives us another indication of what the
percentage is going extinct and then
there is an there are other methods such
as estimating the likelihood that a very
small population an endangered species
will go extinct just by random
fluctuations in the environment I won't
go into that suffice it to say it's been
estimated that the current rate of
extinction worldwide is between a
hundred and a thousand times faster than
it was before the coming of humanity and
some believe those brackets are too low
that it may be approaching 10,000 but
any rate let's call it order of
magnitude about 1,000 times more and
this this translates to about a tenth of
1% of the species extinct are committed
early extinction per year and there are
reasons why that rate is rising which
again I won't go into in detail except
to say that even where forests remain in
fact as in the Amazon they're being cut
through with trails and it being
fragmented and people are going in and
they're damaging forests that otherwise
look intact from aerial surveys and so
we can count on those going up if we is
nothing done it is entirely possible
that if present rates of habitat
destruction and spread of alien species
continue unabated unabated if big if we
could lose half
species of plants and animals on earth
by the end of the century in order to be
too abstract about this let me just
mention the couple of cases of the newly
departed or right on the edge on you
know an emergency in the emergency room
ecological emergency room the
magnificent cerulean paradise flycatcher
of Indonesia thought extinct but just
this year last year a tiny populations
found still hanging on in one of the
small Philippine Islands the golden toad
of Costa Rica which looks which the
male's look like they're painted in
orange dayglo stunning animals Costa
Rica's pride and joy when they were
discovered in the mountain forests of
Costa Rica extinct ten years ago they
saw suddenly went extinct the banditry
snails the beautiful jewel like tree
snails of Hawaii and other parts of
Polynesia rapidly going extinct all
extinct on the island of Moorea
disappearing rapidly in Tahiti have gone
in Hawaii then there are the birds of
Hawaii we know from archaeological
evidence that the that there were at
least 120 species of birds native to
found only in Hawaii when the first
Polynesian put ashore in around 400 AD
they included a hawaiian eagle a
flightless ibis giant goose like birds
the mullah Nola's the rainbow array of
honey creepers that illustrated in
magnificent darwinian a fashion how
certain species can explode or that they
have an adaptive radiation of those 120
species 25 remain and most of those are
endangered a couple of the species
probably are not going to make it more
than a few more years Hawaii is one of
the killing fields of the world of
species biota
the in spite of its lush forest that you
see everywhere when you go there and
beautiful birds flying around those are
in vases they took over and they fit
together so they give you the illusion
of a marvelous Hawaiian fauna they
belong elsewhere they're strangers
during our passage through the
bottleneck the period were now in in
which the greatest challenge is to raise
the lives of the quality of life of
people everywhere to a decent level
while bringing through intact as much of
the natural environment as possible we
should regard these two goals to be
intertwined and they can be approached
in a synergistic manner in which
progress in one economic progress in the
areas where the greatest biodiversity
exists and is threatened and progress in
economic development these to enhance
one another I'll close then with a
special dispatch from the global
biodiversity conservation biodiversity
front which I'm able to give you because
I'm on the boards of directors of three
of the major organizations the Nature
Conservancy Conservation International
as well as affiliated with the World
Wildlife Fund a dispatch that said you a
little bit about what is done about the
hemorrhaging of seco systems and species
and how the problem can be solved and
how much it can how much it will cost
first it turns out and now I'm i hope i
can add a little element of cautious
optimism here it turns out that large
blocks of the last remaining natural
environment in wilderness areas can be
preserved at surprisingly low cost and
in such a way as to yield greater
economic profit to the country's owning
them and it's as simple as this for
apparently many of the tropical
countries with with with existing
reserves of forest logging companies are
operating on a very thin margin profit
margin they can be out competed by
conservation groups using private gifts
which are then leveraged by grants from
the global environment fund and we're
Bank for as little as ten dollars an
acre and often much less conservation
concessions can be established as their
call as opposed to logging concessions a
replaced logging concessions in which
countries otherwise prepared to yield a
large part of their territory to logging
operations turn instead to protect the
forest or trust fund can be set up in
the same way with the proceeds being
paid to the country for preserving and
managing large reserves or the logging
rights can be purchased in some cases or
as little as a dollar an acre the Nature
Conservancy in the Conservation
International for example double the
size of the madidi reserve in Bolivia
the Magnificent tropical reserve by
buying the logging Raja rights for a
dollar a neighbor you know I think
you're beginning to get the idea and
particularly when you know that in these
countries you can that the guards guides
stewards in the local population would
consider 400 or 500 dollars a year and
many of them in many other places as
being an excellent salary and get the
idea that this is not to to take the
first big move toward preserving areas
is is not out of reach finally the land
can be purchased outright now along with
this of course has to be sustainable
economic development so the major global
organizations which are the spearheads
right now the world conservation
movement although the heavy lifting has
to be done by governments most of the
support for global conservation six
billion dollars a year is coming from
governments but the major conservation
organizations are now have it are they
now up to operating budgets of about a
hundred million a year I witnessed with
a while the membership of the World
Wildlife Fund us grow in the in the
1980s from a hundred thousand
to a million than just ten years so
there is this kind of support building
and it is becoming within the reach of
the of our NGOs and the non-governmental
organizations itself particularly with
leverage funding and as they do this
they are putting in a lot of effort and
a lot of planning and feel work using
teams of Nationals scientists economists
workmen and so on in these countries to
introduce a less invasive means of
drawing income from the forest from eco
tourism to to sustainable harvesting at
least the products even apart from
logging looking to measures such as
Kyoto style carbon sequestration credits
getting income from that by trades and
outright purchase and so it seems
evident that there it will be possible
to build in many of the countries where
the weather biodiversity is most
threatening as a an improved economic
environment while saving the parts and
because of the forest so research
management advice and economics and
government policy and science are the
hallmark of the major the global
conservation organizations now and I
find it very promising they have many
partnerships in the corporate world they
have they have success records
sufficient to draw money from the major
lending organizations and so it there
has been a a promising start in the last
well as they tell us 10 years now
another point of entry and solution is
the preservation of hotspots those
particular forest
coral reefs and other local habitats
that are both endangered and contain the
largest number of kinds of plants and
animals found nowhere else recent
research has revealed that just 25 of
these terrestrial hot spots which have
begun to review and to be come under
review for example in this in a series
in the national Geographics out they'll
be much better known to the for the
public 25 of the hot spots cover only
one point four percent of the land these
are the hottest of the hot spots and
I'll tell you at several of them that
would be like the Western Ghats with
India Madagascar forest the forest of
particularly the forest but also the the
river systems of the tropical and easy
extend from Venezuela to Bolivia new
caledonia the the floral floral istic
floristic a very rich scrub land of
southwestern Australia of the cape and
of end of Southern California the the
Atlantic forest of Brazil the forests of
western of western Africa and so on
these 25 terrestrial hotspots cover 1.5
a four percent of the land but are the
exclusive homes that is they are the
only place where are found forty-four
percent of all the known species of
vascular plants and thirty-six percent
of all of the known mammals birds
reptiles and amphibians from my point
here is that endangered species are are
not distributed evenly over the surface
of the earth you know so you're going to
have to somehow set aside half of
bolivia or all of texas in order to
protect the endangered species of a
country but they are their key areas
often not always Unferth of it often
well remove
from most the denser human habitations
and by focusing on these hot spots you
can we can make immediate progress not
all of the hot spots that I've indicated
are in remote jungles some are close at
home Hawaiian rainforest california
coastal sage the lake wales sand ridge
of central florida another hot spot
these are the parts of the world and
which resources should be focused
immediately and then in addition we have
the remaining tropical forests
wildernesses which are three in number
true willders has remained in the Amazon
a congoleum basin of Africa and New
Guinea and we need to focus on those
it's clear that progress in global
conservation then engaging in smart
philanthropy and smart conservation
targeted for the areas where you can do
the most immediately at least at an
affordable cost this is dependent on
joint enterprises of the private sector
government and science this is the Iron
Triangle government private sector
science and technology we have to know
exactly what is at stake what has to be
done and how to do it and to develop a
strategy of aid development attractive
to people everywhere and to their
governments to and right now it's a
private sector working through the
environmental non-governmental
organizations that form the spearhead of
the global conservation effort the
largest of these organizations the
aforementioned Conservation
International for example Nature
Conservancy and World Wildlife Fund are
now large enough to form meaningful
partnerships with a World Bank united
nations as well as work with the CEOs of
larger corporation many of whom are
performing relatively selfless public
service as member
the boards and backed by hundreds of
smaller NGOs I think most of you know
operating its levels from cities and
countries to international and what
makes them special is that the NGOs are
more entrepreneurial and innovative and
flexible in governments but again the
governments are going to have to do the
heavy lifting once the leadership is
established once the problems are made
made clear and once what needs to be
done and the price connected specified
recent estimates made two years ago at a
conference at Caltech called defying
nature's end I love that title that was
biologist economist Andalite made the
estimate that we could save it is
compatible to save with the right
economic strategy and and and political
relations and and involving it in
foreign policy and so on we could save
the core areas of the 33 tropical forest
wildernesses and we could in addition
save the 25 hottest hot spots securing
those that are already in reserves and
setting aside and concessions or
purchased the others this could be done
with about twenty eight billion dollars
in one single payment now if that seems
like a lot keep in mind that that is one
part in a thousand one tenth of one
percent of the world domestic product
that's the approximately 25 to 30
trillion dollars cumulative gross
national product of all the countries
where world domestic product one part in
a thousand of their annual
product in one payment could do this so
furthermore it can be pointed out that
another estimates made by economist and
biologists in 1997 was that biodiversity
and the natural ecosystems of the world
through all of the services that are
given from soil renewal water
purification atmosphere changing flood
control so on and on providing natural
nurseries for fish production and the
like give us in the vicinity of 30
trillion a year in free services so
wiping them out is not good economics
the central problem of the new century
then in my opinion and to repeat is
therefore how to raise the poor to an in
durable quality of life while preserving
as much of the natural world as possible
as we pass through this bottleneck both
the poor and the biological diversity
are concentrated in the developing
countries with eighty percent of the
population and virtually all the
population growth of the world today the
solution to the problem has to flow from
the recognition that both depend on the
other the poor especially the nearly 1
billion that are absolutely destitute
have very little chance to improve their
lives in a devastated environment
conversely the natural environments
where most of biodiversity hangs on
can't survive the press of land hungry
people who have nowhere else to go and
no other lands to convert to agriculture
I hope I've added to the conviction a
little bit shared by growing numbers of
thoughtful people in all walks of life
that this problem can be solved the
resources to do so exist those who
control them have every reason to
achieve that goal and not least their
own security our security at the end of
the day however I think it will come
down to an ethical decision because of
civilization it's able to envision
God to envision afterlife to undo
envision all afterlife to talk about and
the embarkation two for the colonization
of space will surely find the way to
save the integrity of this magnificent
planet and the life that it harbors and
I thank you for listening
thank you
I i believe and correct me if I'm wrong
that we have time for a few questions if
that's or comments accusations other
interpretations of data yes my opinion
consilium is the seminal book of the
21st century and so it pains me when I
see it on the main Virginia and amazing
the floor to see more aggressive
responses such as Wendell Barry's life
I just like you address that new go yes
certainly the that's an interesting
point in the book conciliation Knopf and
I thank you for the compliment the in
the final chapter which was entitled to
what end I mean where the hell do we
think we're going what do you know what
are we going to what he hope to end up
with well I argued that we we really
want to end up with a healthful and
plentiful and an extremely interesting
world which is what the biosphere
offices and I I went through some of the
arguments and of course the heavy
emphasis of concilium swooped on science
and technology not as not as any new
creed by any means not as a substitute
for religion but as a the means to
understand the real world in the need in
the way we have to understand it if we
are going to survive and do well as a
species Wendell Berry one of the icons
of the environmental movement and a
wonderful man poet farmer but
pastoralist I wrote an entire book I
think he its title his life as a miracle
which was an objection to the themes of
consilience and subsequently he and I
held had a congenial exchange of letters
and you know he his argument was that
our problems are due to science and
technology run amok in a sense I guess
that's true but then the solution that
he would like is a major shift in
worldview in philosophy and I couldn't
disagree with that either except that
it's highly unlikely to achieve within
any time you know that that would mean
saving the world's biological diversity
in natural environments we just can't
pull that all someday maybe the 22nd
century we will have that vision and
we'll have a small enough population
coming down but any rate that's he felt
that I was
trying to direct the conservation
movement in the wrong well to pull it in
the wrong direction and I you know we
had a nice exchange in this and you know
he's just teach us wrong I said gosh I
said Wendell you know you know I I wish
this were all true but you know we don't
want to be in the position of a shaman
say in an Amazonian amerindian village
who is practicing the the rituals and
and the medicine and thousand years and
has accounts of the whole world who lead
his people with who one day here's the
the bulldozers and the chainsaws and and
then there's a poison in the water it's
mercuric chloride what is mercury
chloride we don't want to be like that
shot you know with no understanding of
what's happening in the world and
science and technology got us where we
are today science and technology have
got to get us out you know I'd like to
take the opportunity to read one
paragraph is that a copy of the book
which this is my letter to thorough
henry david thoreau in which i fill him
in on what's happening
and I talked about you know I give him
my interpretation I think the best
interpretation of what he was trying to
achieve and how he in a way stumbled
upon the beginnings of the American
environmental heavy and this is relevant
to Wendell Berry who died you know for
whom I have the greatest respect mrs.
how I concluded it Henry my friend thank
you for putting the first element of the
ethic in place now it is time to summon
a more encompassing wisdom the living
world is dying the natural economy is
crumbling of beneath our vet busy feet
we have been too self-absorbed to
foresee the long-term consequences of
our action and we will suffer a terrible
loss unless we shake off our delusions
and move quickly to a solution science
and technology led us into this
bottleneck now science and technology
must help us find the way through and
out you once said that all deeds for old
people and new deeds are for new I think
that in historical perspective it is the
other way around you were the new and we
are the old can we now be the wiser for
you here at Walden Pond the lamentation
of the morning dove and the green frogs
drunk that's how he described it talk
across the pre-dawn water or were the
true reasons for saving this place for
us it is an exact knowledge of what that
truth is all that it implies and how to
employ it and best effect so to truth we
will have them both you and I and
Wendell Berry and all those now and
forever to come who accept the
stewardship of nature that was
yes your commented once to Robert Wright
some years ago that you always enjoyed
taking bets these subjects and bringing
Porter out of them I think you're still
at that thank you especially for them to
finally our solutions and showing the
rest of us how you do it thank you very
much thank you for that too I wasn't a
question but I forgive you yes you've
written a lot about some sorry about the
unity of how Sciences are coming
together and out of their disciplines
are coming together do you think yea
sorry I'm saying this is falling on one
of the previous questions you've written
a lot about how sciences and other
disciplines are slowly coming together
do you think that this will ultimately
have a big effect on helping
biodiversity and howdy how do you feel
that that will happen oh yes the
question is if it is true as I you know
as I argued in conchiglie ins that the
disciplines of science are not slowly
swiftly coming together will that have
an effect on the preservation of a non
saving biodiversity you betcha because
one of the major developments in biology
itself I see the beginnings of it
already in addition to a coalescing of
the of the level of organizations of
biological disciplines from you know
from the community studies of ecosystem
and ecosystems of ecology through
through the organismic biology evolution
down to or to a cell biology and now the
latest developments molecular biology of
genomics and proteomics this is now
getting the methods are getting so
modularized meaning put into modules of
technology that are easily usable and
principles that now make more and more
sense when they are enunciated in terms
of the other levels or
the molecules ecosystem to organ and so
on that we now it's possible for
scientists to move back and forth and
one of you know a young scientist now
starting in the ecosystems are organisms
just thinks little of going right down a
molecular level molecular biologists are
beginning to fill up the journals with
studies of comparison of genomes and so
on so what we are doing what we're
finding now is not only this unifying
trend in biology as a pure science but
also finding the new attention on the
part of science a new awareness of the
necessity of studying diversity you know
the diversity itself these maps that I
was just talking about and getting a
page for each species and beginning to
develop an encyclopedia of like that was
for each species we can start filling
them all the way from the place that has
an ecosystem found to which the
molecular genetics of its population
variation so once that takes hold and it
becomes evident to the panjandrums of
science and biology in particular then
we will see a lot more attention paid to
biodiversity of what's happening to it I
hold yes how you would address one of
the current immediate crisis going on
and I'm talking about the results of the
volcanic eruption in Africa that has
spilled lava to like a view and laiki
view is home to a fairly large number of
endemic species of the half the crow
mean specifically some are found there
and in Lake Victoria Lake Victoria has
its own problems but because of the the
development in the area in the dams Lake
key view has less turnover less input
and how would you address trying to
preserve the diversity of those species
this time I don't know if you heard that
excellent question but it had to do with
oh
where do natural events like the
volcanic eruption that that has extended
lava flows into lake people how is the
destruction they do how is it affected
by damage changes already wrought by
humans right okay well no better example
exists of the of how these hipple
effects work together and what we see
over and over again is that seldom do
does just one factor you know like
invasive species or reduction of habitat
and so on prove to deliver the killing
blow to a species it happens but it's
it's relatively uncommon much more
common is that it's a combination of
circumstances each species dies its own
death and nowadays of course a thousand
times faster at the hands of humanity
and here we have an example where if the
fauna the habitat available to the fauna
is reduced if pollution is increased if
overharvesting has diminished the
populations and so on then when you have
a natural disaster like heavy sulfur
pollution into a lake like evil then you
can have a lot of species knocked out
that would otherwise have survived but
now cannot because their populations are
so low I think that's that's if there's
any broad general principle of modern
conservation biology that's got to be
one yes yes
consequences and contacts of
biodiversity organisms can both give and
take life and as an epidemiologist I
would be interested in your comments
about the public health consequences of
aspects of biodiversity yes a very good
point what is the epidemiological
consequences of biodiversity loss and
habitat destruction unfortunately we
don't have any evidence of pathogenic
viruses and bacteria being among the
extinct species and I think the reason
for this is that when we went up to 6
billion we provided them with a
magnificent banquet so that they could
increase their populations who enormous
size and have distributions going around
the world not too long ago in science I
call it your attention as a as a
marvelous satirical a report in in
science management science magazine
editorial by up by Tom Eisner and Paul
early in which a leader of the pathogens
the bacteria and viruses is reporting
the state of affairs and how humanity
has played into their hands and how
great a future everything looks like and
now especially you know they're carrying
is there even begun to carry us around
the world etc etc so all sorts of that's
that's a truth and the very many ways
our overpopulation in our pollution are
you know are living in dense clusters
and our destroying a natural environment
in many cases it appears in Africa for
example probably occurs in other
tropical environments the bringing the
forest down and therefore bringing some
of these pathogens to humanity right
close by can start epidemics on their
own mosquitoes and
viruses or so on there now flying and
looking for blood at lower lower down
it's a tremendous country but you know
there's also a big reason it's another
big reason for getting a world
biodiversity map you know getting all
the organisms identified and knowing
something about them because when we do
that particularly from mike morgan and i
would hope you would agree that that
then we will be in for fewer nasty
surprises you know news diseases
suddenly popping up and we don't know
where they came from had no idea that
that organism even existed now we can
take care of it we well we are in a
better position to handle it and the
same is true for these invasive species
we can predict what species might be
ready to land on our shores and which
ones would be the most instructor and
sewing yes
form and how we are more part where it's
leading to a better understanding of how
we're more part of the the biodiversity
how we as humans are connected to the
animal and plant community how do you
think that our better understanding of
our commonality of form to other animals
will lead to higher morals and ethics in
this question
this was a very good question this the
question was how does modern biologist
demonstration of commonality of not only
ultimate ancestry through evolution but
also even some of the genes we share for
example fruit flies to people like the
homeobox genes that organize a
anterior-posterior a segmentation
organization of organism how might this
add to our sense of some commonality
with the rest of life and serve as a
premise or as a you know as an argument
for an ethic of biodiversity
conservation and I think that adds a
great deal because part of the reason
why we've wiped out so many species that
we didn't need the wipeout through
ignorance and just sheer greed we you
know humanity is the sense that we've
had cultivated particularly I'm sorry to
say by the Abrahamic religions and and a
general ideology of world expansion the
feeling that we've had that we are apart
from nature we very special we were just
you know we may have been created
somehow of it but we are now in a
angelic or somewhere between the angels
and the rest of life dark angelic
existence here on this planet and I
think as we understand ourselves as a
product of the biosphere as a biological
species of biological world exquisitely
adapted to this particular environment
this disc liberal physical environment
created a biosphere that this is the
cradle a cradle and that though this is
our home and these are actually
literally genetic relatives with much
commonality in genetic and and and other
devices in other other systems that we
are likely to be shall we say a little
less arrogant and with
melody comes moral behavior maybe maybe
one more and then let you escape yes yes
once these groups like the nature
conservancy these days in the last five
years especially switching from a
strategy of simply protecting remnant
ecosystems to actually expanding them by
buying damaged lands around them and
restoring the land that surrounds them I
was wondering if you have any opinions
about the emerging emerging science of
ecological restoration this was a
question what about ecosystem
restoration I didn't bring it up because
you know I didn't have time but this is
certainly part of the the next big phase
in conservation science and activities
finding ways to restore and grow these
environment you know I mentioned and
that is that there is a society of
restoration ecology at journal a growing
cadre of scientists dedicated
conservationists who are moving into
restoration now going to these
threatened hotspots and trying to figure
out how to grow them because you know as
I just saying if you if you can make
them larger than you can you'll have
less extinctions as simple as that so
that that's worth noting in passing that
yes this is a this is now an important
development already and it's a big part
of the future of biology and
conservation thank you very much
with Wilson is honorary curator in
entomology for the Museum of Comparative
Zoology at Harvard University he's
written numerous books including two
Pulitzer Prize winners on human nature
and the ants his latest is the future of
life it's published by konov for more
information visit their website at a
dash a Knopf com